120 yaşındaydım
askeri okuldan yeni ayrılmıştım o günün
parasıyla tam 110 bin dolar borcum vardı
bir hikaye anlatmak için güzel bir
başlangıç Çünkü eski patronu söyle derdi
bir hikaye çok önemlidir açılış ve
kapanış sanatıdır İkisi de mükemmel
olmalı verdi Benim mükemmel bir
başlangıç Hikayem vardı çünkü o dönemde
dünyada benim kadar bu şansız da sahip
olan çok fazla insan yoktu askeri okulu
dereceyle bitirmiştim denizler bu
kulunda da not ortalaması en yüksek on
öğrenciden biriydim bu durumda baş etmem
gerekiyordu birçok arkadaşım ailesinden
destek aldı bu tazminatı ödemek ve bu
durumdan kurtulmak için çok şükür ki
benim ailemin öyle bir durumu yoktu
Bunlar benim mücadele etmem gerekiyordu
hemen aldım kağıdı kalemi elime ve dedim
ki ne yapabilirim PES 2009 yılında 2008
yılında büyük mortgage krizi vardı
Amerika'da ve Amerika Merkez Bankası ilk
kez her yıl bir füzyon dolar para
basarken 3 trilyon dolar para basmaya
başladı bu şu demekti dünyada para
artıyor Bu Ticaret arttıracak Ticaret
artarsa olacak Lojistik ihtiyaçlarını
üstüne çıkacak kamyon gemi uçak
üretimleri artacak önümde hemen birisi
yaptım ve dedim ki bu alanda benim
çalışabileceğim yer ve bu tazminatı öde
bileceğim meslek gemi İnşaat
Mühendisliği olabilir Zaten Deniz harb
Okulu böyle bir altyapı vardı Hemen
İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi gemi
inşaatı ve gemi makineleri mühendisi ne
geçtim çalışmaya başladım o dönem şöyle
bir şansım vardı son sınıf öğrencileri o
kadar çok Demir etmiyor ki son sınıf
öğrencilerine 4 bin dolar civarında maaş
oluyor dedim ki Nuri yaslan arkana iki
senede biz bu işten kurtuluruz kardeşim
ilk seneyi bitirdiğim Ne oldu gemi
inşaat sektörü çok
Ya ben 110 bin dolar ve sektörü çökmüş
bir mühendis olarak Aslında baktığın
zaman ortada Kalmıştı bir önce yaptığım
yaptım yani yapamayacaklarını odaklanma
dım Evet yapacağım Çok şey vardı
Hayatının geri kalanını bahanelerle
güllük gülistanlık ve ateşe biliriz işte
başıma Bunlar geldi şunlar gel Hayır
yapmadım o dönemler açlığımızı çıkarmak
için üniversitede böyle organizasyon
işleri yapıyorduk şu herkes yapmıştır
biraz satıyorduk organizasyon yapıyorduk
sene sonunda bir liste yaptık biz seni
baktık e Kardeşim biz öğrencilerden sene
sonra bir birim para kazanmışız sponsor
diye bir şey var Onlar 11'in para
kazanmışız Ben şimdi geniş anlarınız
bilmiyorum Sponsor ne ne işe yarar dedim
ki burada ben aylık var Bunu bir
bakmamız lazım düşünmemiz lazım
reklamcılıkla İlk defa o noktada
tanıştım dedim ki Tamam Nuri senin yeni
Kaynanan Burası oluyor birazcık
araştırdım dedim ki ben burada yol
yürürüm hemen kendine bir Ajans buldum
dedim bu işi öğrenmem gerekiyor daha
üniv o sensin ki çalışmaya başladım bir
sene geçti çalıştığımız ajansla çok
büyük markalarla 5 ödül kazandık ilk
senede Patron geldi Hemen yanıma dedi ki
bu Nuri dile benden ne dilersen ya dedim
ki ben ayrılmak istiyorum Ne dedi Ben
dedim gitmek istiyorum Çünkü o dönem
çalıştığımız Ayaz küçük bir azalsın ben
şunu gördüm ay sonu çok güzel bir lafı
var doğal boşluktan nefret eder diye siz
bir yere gidip boşluğu doldurdukça sizin
önünüze yeni boşluklar açılır ben girdim
500'ü Kazan o zaman daha fazla gitmem
lazım dedim o zaman küçük kitleleri
ilgilendiren reklamlar yapıyorduk Biz
daha kitlesel reklamları öğrenmenin
yolunu Düşün daha büyük bir ajansa
çalışmam gerekiyordu müsaade istedim
ayrıldım Şansıma da önemli bir yarışma
vardı meşhur bir kempen dergisi
düzenliyor gelişmeyi ve şu şartları
vardı işte 25 yaşın altında olan Gençler
biz yarışma yapacağız ve bu yarışmayı
kazanan da bir ödül kazanacak çok güzel
Ben dedim ki belki Kendimi göstermek
için sivri göndermek da olabilir
yarışmaya katıldım
Ama tabii Ben yarışmada birinci oldum
Ama bilmediğin bir şey vardı meğersem o
yarışmanın Hayır o benim girmek
istediğin bir bacağım sarı var ya Birisi
Türkiye'nin en büyük 10 Ajansı'nın Kredi
direktörünün oluşuyormuş şans Ondan
sonra
alametifarika kreatif direktörü Emlak
karpuzu yanına gelmedim ki Nuri sunumu
çok beğendim bizim ajansta birlikte
çalışabiliriz
inanılmaz yani dedim ki hiç ekstra bir
şey yapmıyorum ve o gün itibariyle ben
alametifarika ya girdim ve Garanti
Bankası iki reklam yazarından biri oldu
şimdi yanlış anlamayın Hani bana dile
benden ne dilersen diyen bir patronun
vardı ya o zaman bana 3000 maaş
veriyordu Emre abinin bana deneme süresi
için teklif ettiğimiz bir birimdir O
benim ev Kiram bir nokta birbirimizi
Yani ben aldığımı parayla Ev kira mı
asla diyemezdi ama şunu yapmadım ya
Emrah'ın ben bu parayla geçer ama
birazcık daha para demedim şunu yaptım
gittim kendime bir arkadaşımız mayın
plan diye düşündüm üç ay boyunca bakar
mıydım Ya bu duymadım ama Alamet teki o
koltuğundan asla vazgeçmedim şimdi bizim
reklamcının arasında bir şey vardır
kazandığım parayla genellikle böyle
çıkan son model spor ayakkabıları
alırsın Birazcık böyle kendi fiyakalı
falan yatırım yaparsın Ben de tam
tersiydi Ben patron da gördüğüm
kitapları ona okuyorsa gidiyordum
amazondan sipariş ediyorum Türkiye'de
yoktu sağolsun Ucuz kitap okuyordur
maaşımı yarısı kitapları biliyorum o
kadar çok okudum O kadar çok
araştırıyorum ki ve geçtiğimiz süreç o
kadar zorlu bir süreçteki Şöyle bir
gerçek vardır insanlar kendinden
fedakarlık ettikçe daha da böyle
hırçınlaşır bir ödül İster yani kardeşim
bu kadar değer çekiyorum birşey olmadı
Ben tam ortada böyle bir tane ya bu
şöyle okurken bir kampanya Böyle Bir
yarışmada yarışma diyor ki işte Biz yurt
dışında bir şirketiz dünyanın en çok
tıklanan 100 internet sitesinden bir
tenis Vay ama bir sıkıntımız var nedir
Biz yetişkin içerikleri üreten bir
pornosiz ve reklam yapmak istiyoruz
yapamıyoruz Çünkü içeriklerinizi Hepsi
açık seçik kullandığımız kelimelerin
yarısı küfür O yüzden biri çıkıp bize
reklam yapmanın bir formülü bulursa biz
onunla bir senelik bir reklam kampanyası
Global kreatif direktörler anlaşacağız
dedim ki belki bir şeyler yapabilirim
şimdi reklam kampanyası düşünürsen ilk
yapmanız gereken şey bir kampanya
kurgusu oluşturmak ve Dünya'yı kelimeler
yönetir önce bir cümlesini Bulmak
kelimesinin kavramı bulmak Ben 34 sayede
buldum cümleyi Biz olsun bir şarkısı
vardı o gün kız lavlar olanı çıkartıp
yerine handy koydum Allah Yani Allah'ın
bildiğini kuldan saklama gerek yok dedim
ki Bu sitenin sloganım olsun biz birini
bunu arttırırız ama bir kampanyanın aynı
zamanda bir de görseli ihtiyacı var
Şimdi bunu tamamlayacak bir görsel
ihtiyacımız vardı dedim ki ya Nuri elimi
koyayım Elimi çekeyim işte yukarıda
slogan yatsın burada elimi göstereyim
bak çok kör göze parmak çok anlaşılır
Benimki daha böyle cin bir fikir bulmam
lazım şu gördüğünüz hareket
erkeklerin mastürbasyon yapma
hareketidir dedim ki bunu koyayım ben
elini böyle getirdiğim anladım ki Aha
burada bir şey var Bunun yanına
Aynısından bir tane daha koyduğumuz
zaman kalp oluyor ve Siz iki tane eli
kötü niyetli eli dünyanın en masum
simgesinin içine gizliyorsunuz Ben
bununla birlikte kampanyalı tamamladım
ve puan owen 3000'den fazla reklamcı
dünya çapında başlattığı Kampanyayı
kazanarak
Global kreatif direktörü oldu yaşım 25
bu sağ tarafta gördüğünüz ekran Times
Square o Eller Benim ellerim bu ve bu
yarışma ile beraber biz kazandığımız
zaman [ __ ] at
ben ilk 100 şirketten bir tane Siz ondan
sonra yarışmalı kurgularken psikoloji
bölümü çok kritik bir şey yazıyor Ben
dedim ki yapmamız gereken temel şey şu
bilinirliğinizi arttırmak istiyorsak
örtmeye kazanacağız ne demek bu para
harcamadan insanları mecra olarak
kullanacağız öyle ister yapacağız ki
insanlar bizim yaptığımız işleri
paylaşacak bunu yaptığınızda amacınız
oydu bilmem kaç bin dolara günlük kirası
olabilir poster verdik bekliyoruz ki
insanlar Hadi haber yapsın paylaştığın
etsin Bizim de bildiğiniz artık Kimse
paylaşmalı yani o güne kadar biz o kadar
molekül etmiştik hikayeyi Kimse gelip de
atamam pornop tam süper iğne oyası
demedi dedi ki daha beter bir şey
yapmamız lazım Daha da görebiliriz
indirdik
bu İncirlik ya Bütün parayı verdim şey
indirdik Ondan sonra oldu biliyor
musunuz 46 ülkede 400'den fazla habersiz
içinde independe guardia New York Times
şöyle bir hayatım tamam süper tarihinde
ilk kez bir poster indirildi Biz bununla
beraber milyonlarca dolarlık örtmede
kazandık ve benim kredi direktörlüğü bir
seri Kredi direktörü sonunda o ilk
100'de olan şirket ilk 10A girdi ve şu
an dünyanın en çok tıklanan ilk 10
sesinden biri hala
var Bununla beraber tabi ben yurt
dışında bir başarı elde ettiğiniz zaman
içinize şu öyle bir şey oluyor Daha ne
yapabilirim daha fazla nereye
gidebilirim kanda bizim Reklamcılık
Festivali vardır Ben cesaretimi topladım
bir hiç partide sonucuna girdi ile
karşılaştık
ekranda gördüğünüz beyefendi adından
Anlaşılacağı üzere kendisi Şövalye yani
İngiltere'nin en ünlü reklamcısı
iliklerine bölümü dedim ki Suar bir
maruzatım var Ben böyle böyle işler
yapan genç reklamcim yaşında genç acaba
yurt dışında bir şeyler yapabilir miyiz
sizinle başkası imkanın var mı
kampanyalı anlattım böyle gülmekten
mojito içiyordum uyku sallandım öyle
yerlere düştü Yani inanılmaz derecede
dedi ki çok sevdim dedi Çok başarısını
tebrik ederim dedi ama dedi sana bir
ağabey tavsiyesi vereceğim nedir dedim
Eğer dedim tasarımcı olsaydın seni hemen
alır götürdüm ama dedi sen dedi bir
reklamcı sın reklam yazarsın yaptığın iş
bulunduğum kültür la la ya o yüzden
gidip en iyisini ülkende yapmam lazım
bunun başka bir yolu yok seni alıp
getirirsen çok zorlarız o tavsiye bekle
Benim hayatımda aldığım altın değerinde
bir tavsiye Çünkü kimse kimseye vermez
ve hemen Ben işin farkına vardım
zorlamadım ve ülkeme döndüm ama aklım
hala ne yapabilirim ne edebilirim gibi
bir hikayede şimdi hikayenin bu kadarını
dinlediğim zaman aklıma şöyle bir şey
nedir Ya ne alaka kardeşim bu kadar şey
arka arkaya nasıl olabilir Size bir
örnek vereceğim metaforlu anlatacağım
bunu bir kola
düşünün okulun içine bir naneli şeker
attığında deneyler var ya İnternet
videolar ne oluyor o köprübatı değil mi
İşte ben okulun içine atılan daire şeker
diyebiliyor musunuz Reklamcılık sektörü
müzik edebiyat sanatla alakalı eğitimler
olan insanların var oldu bir şey ya Ben
akışkanlar mekaniği biliyorum akışkanlar
mekaniği bilen bir adamı reklamcılığın
içine soktuğunuz da neler olacağı aşikar
dedim ki ben buraya odaklanmalıyız Şimdi
aq Bu bir tekne vereceksiniz ve bu
göreceğiniz teknenin fiyatı üç buçuk
milyon euro azimut 116 size çok basit
bir şey sormak istiyorum
Ama bu tekniği Benimki Satın almak
istiyorsunuz Melek ki bunda tasarımını
ben yaptım İnşaat Mühendisliği benim siz
geliyorsunuz bunu alacağım oyun şartım
var Sana bir soru soracağım eğer o
soruya cevap verirsen bu tekniği
alacağım peki nedir Soru yüzer mi
şu an Oğlum bana diyorsunuz ki yüzer mi
ben seçiyorum Garanti edemiyorum yani
yüzer de olabilir yüzmeye edebilir alın
bakın denize indirin karar verir alır
mısınız teknik bakıyorum almaz Ben de
aldım Şimdi bir tane de grafik
göstereceğim üç buçuk milyon euro dedik
ha yanlış anlamayın Bakın bu grafik
dünya reklam harcamalarını gösteriyor
2020 Reklam harcaması 712 milyar dolar
mm
21750 9 milyar dolar ya üç buçuk milyon
Euro'luk tekniği almıyorsunuz 759 milyar
dolarlık bir pazar var ve Reklamcılık
okyanusu'nda yüzden hiçbir geminin yüzme
garantisi yok
kimsenin dedim ki havlu Eğer dedim
kaldırma kuvvetini bulabilirsem Çünkü
fark yok yeni inşaat sektörünün bu
garantiye verebiliyorum Çünkü kaldırma
kuvvetini biliyorum Arşimet keşfetmiş
ama reklamcılıkta böyle bir şey yok Aha
Neden bunu bulursak işte Ama bu pazara
etkileyecek bir şey yapabiliriz oturdum
kendi pazarlarını değiştiren ve
dönüştüren şirketlere baktım Google
Pixel hatim ettim ne yapıyorlar ve
buldum bir sene çalıştım ondan sonra
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi'nde tanıdığım genç
bilgisayar mühendisliğini en sevdiğim
stajyerlerin yanıma aldım ve onları
dedim ki arkadaşlar
Bu Dünyanın şeklini değiştirebiliriz üç
yıla ihtiyacımız var üç yıl 13 yıl
boyunca yol yürüyeceğiz ve ondan sonra
her şey değişecek benim ne var mısınız
Bana dediler ki ya çok güzel
anlatıyorsun da biz ne anlarız ya dedim
kimse bir şey anlamıyor zaten dünyada bu
işle ilgilenen kimse yok sizde var mı
bizde varız biz oturduk elimde kişiyle
ne yaptık biliyor musunuz bilgisayarlara
makinelere reklam izlemeye öğrettik
bu dinozor bir şey yüzbinlerce boyutlu
bir uzaydan bahsediyoruz Google
bilgisayara kedi resmi görmeyi ve
anlamayı nasıl üretiyorsa bilgisayara
reklam izlemeye öğretiyoruz iyi iğne ile
kuyu kazıyoruz acayip zor dedim ki yani
bir sene geçti Bir buçuk sene geçti hep
beraber çalışıyoruz büyük eforlar
sarfediyoruz dedim olmayacak olmayacak
yani çok zor bir şey yapıyoruz sonra
olmuyor musun bir devrim
bu dünyada beni teknolojileri 100 bin
kat hızla gelişmeye başladı bizim
topladığımız ve makine öğrettiğimiz
veriyi yapay zeka ve makine öğrenmesi
mükemmel bir formata dönüştürdü ve
sorulara çıktı ortaya biliyor musunuz
dünyanın en derin ikiyüzbin boyutlu Bir
Uzay içinde reklamları analiz eden ve
Geleceğe yönelik efektini Prodüksiyon
yapan yani etkisini pratik dediler
öngörülen bir da temel oluşturur nerede
Türkiye'de tamamı Türk bir ekiple ve
789 milyar dolar bir pazara şekli
değiştirecek şekilde burada omzo ismi
bu değiştirdik
bu burada en önemli şey bu ne işe
yarayacak diyebilirsiniz bugün hala
reklamcılığın en büyük problemi bir
alfabesinin olmaması Bugün bir insana
Sen ne tarz reklamlar seviyorsun dediğin
zaman bunun bir açıklaması yok Niye
reklamcılığın alfabesi yok biz ne yaptık
biliyor musunuz platformlu Darwin
türlerin kekinde evrim teorisini nasıl
Açıklıyor sa biz bu platformda aynı şey
yaptık taksonomi
ve televizyonlarında açıyorsunuz
televizyonlarını açtığınızda reklamları
beğenmiyorsunuz değil mi Niye Çünkü
Reklamların yüzden 78'i birbirinin
aynısı bugün size bunu Söyleyebilecek
tek forvet platform var o nazof Çünkü
ikiyüzbin boyutlu uzayda reklamları
atomik parçalarını ayırıyor ve bu adamı
parçaladıktan sonra 278 birbirine
hangisi yüzde yetmiş sekizde aynı olan
bir uçaklar ekran bayan ihtimaliniz yok
çünkü magnon şema çatışma teorisine göre
Sizin bir şey beğenilmez için önce
şaşırma nız gerekiyor Hayret ve bununla
beraber takip etmeniz gerekiyor önemli
şey Bu iki tane ortak tek var alfabe
mizden bahsedeyim size birincisi Boys
Over ters ikincisi mi Refik bu 178
ekranın içinde kullanılan iki alfabe iki
harf söylüyorum sizi ne demek bu dış
sesi şey anlatıyor görüntülerde sesini
anlattı şeyin aynısını görürsünüz Ya
bunun reklam değil ki bunun adı anons
bunları reklam değil bunun için bu o
paralar harcamanıza gerek yok Peki
bugüne kadar niye böyle devam ediyor
Çünkü bunun çözümünü bulan çaresini
bulan kimse yok Ev hanımları nasıl
reklamlar beğeniyor Amerika'daki ev
hanımları nasıl reklamlar veriyor var mı
bu dünyada açıklayabilecek kimse yok
Niye alfabe İşte biz o alfabeyi bulduk
ve hayatımda Zirve diyebileceğim çok yer
yaşadım bunu çok ne söyleyebilirim
ödüller kazandım çok iyi ajansa de
çalıştım ama diğerlerinden farkın Belki
bugün burada olmamı sağlayan şey şuydu o
ilizyonun içinde kalmadım yaptığım şey
şuydu bir yükseltide olduğunun
farkındaydım ve etrafında hiçbirşey
görmediğini zaman ben zirvedeyim demedim
çünkü yükselen ben değilim alçalan
duvarlar the bunu görmem benim için çok
önemliydi ve şunu yaptım Ne zaman bir
tepenin üstüne çıksam fırınımı Pırtımı
topladım aşağı indirmeye biliyor musunuz
yükselmek dediğiniz şeyi böyle bizim
kanatlarımız Yok ya biz melek değiliz
biz insanız yükselmek dediğinizi tepeden
diğer TP uçarak gidemezsiniz önce
bilmeniz lazım Ben ödül kazandım aşağı
indim iyi bir ajansa çalışmaya başladım
aşağı indim dünya çapında reklam
kampanyaları yaptım aşağı indim kana
Türkiye'den davet edilen ve en geç
konuşmacı oldum Aşağı in Çünkü
Tepelerden inmeden dağlara tırmanamaz
sınız teşekkür ederim o